everyone's favorite tricks to god is
back from the grave
again tom hiddleston's loki has returned
to take the marvel cinematic universe by
storm
in a new trailer for his upcoming series
on disney plus
let's break down the small details you
may have missed in the latest
loki trailer from the looks of the
trailer it's clear that whether he likes
it or not
loki is going to be working closely with
an organization
called the time variant authority aka
the tva
in the trailer owen wilson's character
mobius explains to the notorious
trickster
that the moment he picked up the
tesseract in avengers end game
he disrupted the natural flow of time
that's where the tva comes in
but what is the tva the members of the
time variants authority are essentially
time cops are in charge of ensuring all
the various timelines on the marvel
universe stay on track
as loki points out they are an extremely
bureaucratic body
who seem to exist with the sole goal of
keeping the expansive marvel multiverse
from getting too
convoluted at the 11 second mark of the
new loki trailer
one can spot tall stone statues inside
the time variants
authority building just a few seconds
later there are three large wooden faces
carved into the walls these three beings
are actually pretty major
when it comes to marvel comics as they
represent the timekeepers
first appearing in thor issue 243
under the name of the time twisters the
timekeepers were three entities created
by he who remains
the last director of the time variance
authority the purpose of the timekeepers
is to teach those in the current cycle
how to avoid mistakes of the past and to
ensure retired tva employees maintain a
good quality of life
of course there were also some realities
where they manifested as the sinister
time twisters strayed from their
designated course and traveled back in
time to destroy the universe instead of
protect it
there's plenty to get excited about in
the new loki trailer
especially when it comes to a huge movie
star joining the marvel cinematic
universe
for the first time fans get to meet owen
wilson's loki character
mobius m mobius a manager within the
time variants authority
who appeared in the original marvel
comics from the looks of it wilson's
mobius will be an integral part of loki
teaming up with the asgardian trickster
to help restore reality
and fix all the wrongs loki himself
created after he stole the tesseract
beyond a role in west anderson's yet to
be released projects to french dispatch
wilson hasn't been spending much time on
the big or small screen lately
making loki a welcome return for the
talented performer
the inclusion of a cat in the new loki
trailer might seem innocuous to a casual
marvel fan but in this world
cats are rarely what they seem at first
glance captain marvel fans know that
this cat could very well be a flurkin
a feline like alien creature capable of
some pretty impressive and disgusting
digestive feats
it could also be a clever reference to a
cat thor of marvel comic lore
at one point loki transformed into cat
thor to make nancy whitehead
squirrel girl's best friend smile in any
case after captain marvel's goose turned
out to be much more than a simple cat
there's a chance that this cute little
kitty holds some big secrets
or it could just be an adorable animal
that fans can fawn over
either way we're not mad about it loki
will clearly have to answer to the time
variance authority throughout his series
and the minds behind loki have assembled
a pretty great cast to play these time
cops
including british actress gugu and
batara who seems to be portraying a
high-ranking member of the organization
if embarra looks familiar that's no
surprise
she's been a steady force in hollywood
lately starring in the morning show on
apple tv plus
lending her voice to netflix's to dark
crystal age of resistance
and appearing in the 2020 british comedy
misbehavior you probably also remember
her moving turn in the fan favorite
black mirror episode
san junipero given her talents and
diverse range
and bartura raw is a great choice to add
to the loki cast
and fans will have to wait and see how
her character tangles up with the tricks
to god
something that makes a return appearance
on the second trailer for loki
is the neon blue sign of a store named
roxcut the appearance of an in-universe
store could usually be chalked up to the
production design team
trying to flesh out the world of a
series but this is a marvel property
which means there's likely more to
rock's car than meet ci
the store is possibly connected to the
roxanne corporation
a shady international oil conglomerate
that has appeared in multiple
live-action marvel properties
including agents of shield agent carter
daredevil
cloak and dagger and iron man 3. exactly
how the big box store branch of
roxanne's industry will play into the
narrative of loki remains to be seen
it's likely that the store will be of
some kind of significance though
this is the second time it has appeared
prominently in a trailer for the series
and there's even a rocks card website
that fans can visit
it's something worth keeping an eye on
as loki's june 11th launch date draws
nearer
marvel never officially announced the
one meme osaku as part of the loki cast
but a trio of blink and you missed some
appearances in the new trailer
not only confirmed the lovecraft country
actress's presence on the show
but also gives fans a good look at her
character who hasn't been named as of
this video
the first time a saku's character
appears in the trailer is five seconds
in
she's seen stepping through a portal one
hand gripping loki and the other holding
the tesseracts
this seems to be moments after loki is
arrested for wreaking havoc on the
timeline
as loki is still in his traditional
costume she appears again at the 19
second mark
standing next to loki as he's arraigned
on time crime charges
finally she appears at 148 blocking a
doorway
drawing a sword and preparing for battle
the three moments in this trailer
indicate that masaku's character is some
sort of time variance authority security
officer
responsible for monitoring and
transporting loki
it's exciting to see mo saku in a marvel
property
the british actress's star has been
ascending since she appeared in the
black mirror episode playtest
in 2016. her other notable projects
include the excellent netflix horror
movie his house
and hbo's horror series lovecraft
country
after rumors circulated that sacha lane
best known for her starring role in
american honey
would be joining loki fans were
scrambling for any details about who she
would be playing
thanks to the new trailer they now have
their official first look at lane's loki
character
at around the 1 45 mark in the new loki
trailer
lane's character appears on screen
decked out in what looks like time
variants authority armor
and holding a jousting lance but just
because she's wearing the armor doesn't
mean she's a part of the organization
as the next shot shows lane's character
pummeling a different tva officer
so far there are no other details about
who her character is
so it's unclear why she's fighting the
tva but given loki's powers in
manipulation
it might not be of her own volition as
for the lance this potentially hinted
the scene taking place
in the medieval time period which would
make sense given that loki would jump
around
important moments in real life human
history and stand out events within the
mcu
will her character be a friend or foe to
hiddleston's loki
fans will just have to wait and see loki
is a trickster willing to deceive
whoever he needs to in order to get his
way
in other words he'd make the perfect
politician comic book writer christopher
hastings apparently thought the same
thing
when he came out with a four episode
mini-series in 2016
titled vote loki the premise is simple
loki decides to run in the 2016 u.s
president election
promising that he's always going to lie
to the people as opposed to lying while
pretending he's telling the truth
to everyone's surprise it turns out to
be a fairly effective campaign strategy
as loki ends up garnering a ton of
support from both of the disney plus
loki trailers we've seen so far
it looks like this storyline is getting
adapted at least somewhat
this new trailer doesn't provide a ton
of fresh insight into how vote loki will
be adapted
into the disney plus series which seems
to suggest that this part of the show
will probably only last for a single
installment of the six episode season
one specific scene in the new loki
trailer illustrates just how far back in
time the series will take fans
in one moment loki and what looks like
wilson's mobius
are seen in the town of pompeii italy
right as the mount vesuvius eruption
comes roaring through town
destroying everything in its path the
mount vesuvius eruption happened in 79
a.d
and buried everyone and everything
underneath millions of tons of volcanic
ash
it wasn't until 1748 that people
discovered the well-preserved remains of
the city
and its inhabitants in the loki trailer
it looks like the god of mischief has
the advantage
possibly bartering with mobius as a
volcanic ash hurtles towards them
upon seeing the clip many fans have
posed a very valid question
does this mean loki caused pompei's
destruction it wouldn't be the worst
thing that he's done in his long life
he transformed himself into a snake and
he knows that i love snakes so i went to
pick up the snake to admire it
and he transformed back into himself and
he was like yeah it's me and he stabbed
me near the end of the new trailer
loki is seen winking at a flight
attendant while sporting a black suit
and tie
white shirt black sunglasses and short
nearly cropped hair
it's unclear exactly what's happening
here but it's hard not to see a
resemblance between loki's new look
and the mysterious db cooper on november
24th 1971
a man going by dan cooper hijacked a
boeing 727.
he ultimately parachuted out of the
plane with 200 thousand dollars of
ransom money in hand
the equivalent of about 1.3 million
dollars in 2021 cash
his body has never been recovered and no
one knows what happened to him
why he did what he did or who he really
was we've previously seen loki dressed
as db cooper
in the trailer that premiered in
december 2020 since loki is working with
the tva and will be traveling through
time throughout the series
it makes perfect sense that he'd be
masquerading as one of history's most
notorious and mysterious criminals just
as a loki trailer comes to a close
audiences can see loki sitting with a
mysterious woman
who's facing away from the camera
naturally speculation is running rampant
about who this woman could be
however one theory seems to be rising
above the fray
this woman might be lady loki lady loki
is an integral part of the original
marvel comics
in one instance where loki dies which he
does multiple times in the comics
he's reincarnated into lady sif's body
not only is lady loki one of loki's
important disguises but she also adds a
new layer to the character
who's clearly comfortable existing as
both genders we still don't know who
this woman in the new trailer actually
is
but if she is lady loki fans are
definitely in for a treat
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more luba videos about
the marvel cinematic universe are coming
soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you